if our nature
of reality is truly
the one indivisible
indescribable um whole
that we are and that the nature of
reality is truly
that consciousness that is experiencing
itself across
these eight billion dissociative
boundaries
and that the the idea then would be
i'm curious what you think would it be
fair to use an analogy
like a dreamed symphony been playing
around with this i'm curious what you
think
that we are that that
that unity that unity of a symphony and
that
each one of us in the symphony is
playing a different instrument i'm
playing
the cello you're playing the clarinet
someone else is playing the sax someone
else the drums
and that we're even people that are
playing the same instrument are playing
different melodies or harmonies and that
actually your son
right cosmo's a musician right yes
yeah okay and so the the idea is that
if i'm if and and by the way the
conductor is like a
a is an attractor so there's like a you
know the the mathematical system
there's a mathematical attraction for
our complex system to evolve towards
this attractor which which could be like
a oroboros or something like uh you know
an automata orthogenesis to uh
recursive function or something but the
point is is that like
is the dream symphony analogy a good way
for us to understand like if i'm playing
more out of tune let's say
my cello i'm playing more out of tune
that's because i'm serving to myself but
if you're playing your clarinet and
you're playing it in tune
that's because you're playing service to
other and so the other
so the idea is that we are going through
some sort of a
a dreamed symphonic uh
artistic oneness
evolution and that we can both integrate
into the symphony and differentiate
like in calculus of our
unique contribution how do you how does
that
dream symphony analogy for the nature of
reality resonate
well it does rather assume that
everything
is working together to start with i mean
orchestra
they have to have a shared agenda to
play to have a symphony together
and
excuse me um it's
it's not um immediately obvious that
there is at least as far as a whole of
humanity is concerned
uh a shared symphony i mean the
president of the united states and
you know the various figures and islamic
fundamentalist movements et cetera
i mean the the there's so many different
points of view
the you know hindu nationalists in india
you know chinese asserting their power
etc
it's not clear that everyone sees
themselves as part
of a coordinated symphony of humanity
um and uh for the dream symphony to
i think people would have to sign up to
be part of a dream symphony orchestra
for this particular metaphor to work
uh is not obvious that's the case um
you could argue that there are
underlying creative forces that i mean i
myself think there are
working through history and that
conflict is part of it
and that the conflict plays its part in
the creative
evolution of things i mean a personal
example
when my book sunset free came out
my ted talk my tedx talk in 2013
the called the science delusion was
taken down by 10 from their main website
because of protests from militant
materialists psed myers and jerry coyne
who are both
militant richard dawkins type
materialists
and ted tried to suppress this
talk or at least hide it completely
unsuccessfully
and but this attack uh from these people
who wanted to
stop me having a platform uh led to
enormous controversy on the internet
the result is that at least six million
people who've seen this talk now whereas
before their protests only about 30 000
had seen it
so um they were playing their part and
you know i don't have
a kind of personal hostility to people
like
jerry coyne and stuff i mean they're
playing their part in this drama
but dream symphonies also include
dissonances
i mean music's not all harmony and you
know
the dissonance is a part of it so it may
be that the
jerry coyne is part of this dream
symphony without realizing it
um so okay okay so so it could
also be fair to say that not only is it
that
we may have different national
agendas across the planet uh
in parts of this symphony but also just
that in general
um within the symphony the playing out
of tune is not only when you're
trying to like hoard things in service
to self mentality
but it's also when you are um being
militant
in one specific dogma and
yeah i i think that's very interesting
thank you for pointing that out
yes okay and of course people may also
play altitude out of sheer incompetence
so um
rupert um i want to ask you on a on a
on a telos perspective
um given the fact that artificial
intelligence is now
significantly for deeper emergence so
are virtual realities which are kind of
in a sense
when you when you immerse yourself in
one for an extended period of time
you in a sense could say that holy cow
how am i not already in one how is this
not already one
so we have ai we have vr we have
simulation technology simulation theory
could it be that where these
technologies are
are triangulating on the same thing in
the sense that the eastern
spirituality has been saying for the
longest time that
the dreamer the ultimate dreamer of
infinite consciousness
ends up uh in this dream that we're in
now
wakes up and then goes right back into
another dream as in
the oroboros continues so is the west
what is the telos is the west focus on
aivr
simulation tech could that be what john
smart calls the transcension hypothesis
when we go
inward into these substrates and that we
uh continue the oral boros and that we
keep
going through more and more big bangs
and that that is our
in that is our uh that's our attractor
is that the tilos what do you think
about that
well i think that there's there's a
sense in which artificial intelligence
virtual reality
you know are expanding the realm uh
certainly of what machines can do and
also
of things like games and whatnot um
i think there's a parallel exploration
going on
which is non-technological through this
the um renewed research on psychedelics
because psychedelics after all
a way of opening up the imaginal world
um
particularly the visionary ones i mean
ayahuasca
lsd mushrooms and so on which have uh
an enormously liberating effect on the
imagination for many people
um i mean they're not for everyone and
i'm not advocating indiscriminate use of
psychedelics and especially not
encouraging people to do anything
illegal i mean i have to say these
disclaimers
um but the fact is that um
as well as this exploration um we've
also got a parallel exploration going on
and in fact in places like silicon
valley the
exploration through psychedelics um is
often happening in the same people
who are engaged in in the especially in
computer graphics um and visualizing
things
and virtual reality so i think here
we've got
this expanded range of explorations
that aren't based on technology i mean
personally i think they're more fun when
they're not based on technology i mean
i'm not
very technological myself um but i think
there's an exploration of consciousness
which after all has happened in the east
through
meditative techniques it's happened in
the west through meditative techniques i
mean
contemplative christianity in the middle
ages and
since then in the catholic and the
orthodox tradition of monks and nuns
living in enclosed orders some of them
spend hours a day in
meditation and prayer and they're
exploring realms of consciousness
and they're not just exploring their own
consciousness the whole point is that
through meditation and these spiritual
practices
you come into contact with other forms
of consciousness
that's the whole point of my recent
books and the most recent one being
ways to go beyond and why they work
seven different spiritual practices
um uh which have been scientifically
investigated
and are about exploring these realms of
consciousness
beyond our normal everyday consciousness
so i think what's exciting at the moment
is there's a new phase of spiritual
evolution beginning
through the widespread availability of
spiritual practices
and scientific studies of them and also
all these amazing technological
adventures and i think they're they're
complementary i don't think it's one or
the other
yeah there's a big convergence that is
happening there
and whatever the telos uh ends up being
wherever the
tractor of the complex system is heading
it's inevitably
it in order to be happy and have great
well-being and have good amounts of
peace
and collective prosperity and individual
flourishing
one needs to embody what you write about
in ways to go beyond where you
where you talk about specifically um
also
the practices of doing things like
meditation
i think people also forgot that even the
word yoga
means union in sanskrit it's not holding
stretching positions
and it means union with the divine
whatever your unique
combinatoric is with the divine um
and also gratitude is such a a prominent
one
that is so important and it's the way
that science and spirituality are
converging which you've written about so
much
going out in nature